Finding a location,
organising booth builders,
booking hotels and flights,
planning an event is a lot of work.
travelling to event locations,
blocking time for overnight stays.
It is neither sustainable nor cost efficient.
But there is no alternative to successful networking,
is there?
Perhaps not,
as long as it looks like this.
An online event only works if it feels like a real on-site event.
That's why our events look like this,
or this,
or even like this.
We create a true to life event atmosphere set in an engaging environment.
Accessible from anywhere in the world.
The event environment can be 100% custom designed
and is based on your individual needs.
Communicate your brand's message and integrate sponsors into the event.
In the meeting areas,
participants can connect and chat in video calls.
The content of the conversation stays between the participants.
Our service is GDPR compliant.
Our scalable servers guarantee a lag-free
connection for up to 50,000 participants.
We are the first provider to offset all CO2 emissions that we generate,
making our events a more climate friendly alternative.
Our customers agree,
when done right,
online events work.
That's why 9 out of 10 customers would recommend us.
Meet you offers different pricing models.
Find out which solution suits your needs best.
Book a free consultation call today.